Hello, my name is Maya Ben Ari,
and I'm the product manager
for Android authentication
and authorization.
Our goal is to deliver you the
best, smoothest, most secure
authentication possible.
And I'd like to
share with you some
of the things we're working on.
Passwords suck.
You're asked to enter your
password over and over
throughout the course of a day.
If you have a lock
screen set you
need to enter your pin or
password many times per day.
While we absolutely believe
your personal information should
stay secure, our vision is to
make this experience seamless
and frictionless
so that you will
have to authenticate
fewer times per day
while increasing challenges for
anyone pretending to be you.
When you hold your phone,
it should magically
know that it is with you.
We'd like to
differentiate between you
and someone
pretending to be you.
When your phone is with
you, it can stay unlocked.
As it moves out of
your control, it
should lock to keep
your photos, messages,
and personal information secure.
Our first step in
this direction is
to establish that your
phone is with you.
We're adding multiple
new unlock mechanisms,
such as fingerprint support,
voice identification,
active Bluetooth connections
to your trusted devices,
and trusted places.
For example, active connections
to your trusted Bluetooth
devices can be used to
help authenticate yourself
to your mobile device.
Right now, I'm wearing
an Android wear device.
I currently have a lock
screen set on my phone.
If I unlock my phone and add
my Android Wear to my trusted
devices, my Wear
device can be used
to keep my mobile unlocked.
Now, because I have
an active connection,
if I press the power button
I won't see the lock screen
challenge as before.
You can also set a trusted
place such as your home
or your office.
A place is defined as a
combination of things,
including your location
and networks around you
where you enable your
mobile to stay unlocked.
I know my workplace
is secure, so I
can go in to Trusted Places
and add my work building
as a trusted place.
Because I'm at
work now, my mobile
identifies that it
is in my trusted
places and the next time I
press the power button I won't
see the lock screen challenge.
This is just the beginning
of better authentication
with your mobile device.
With time, we will extend
to additional mechanisms
to establish your
mobile is with you.
Now, the next exciting part is
that once we have established
that your mobile
is with you, you
should be able to use
it to identify you
to other devices such as your
TV, your car entertainment
system, and even your laptop.
If my Chromebook detects
my mobile is nearby
and my mobile identifies
it is with me,
I should be able to log
into my Chromebook account
without the need of
entering my password.
My Chromebook
profile is currently
locked as indicated
by the Lock icon.
If I place my unlocked
mobile nearby my Chromebook,
the Lock icon changes.
Now I can log into my profile
without entering any password.
Finally, in the
future, establishing
that your mobile is
with you could also
eliminate the need
to reauthenticate
for purposes like purchases.
Why should I reenter my
password for small purchases
if my phone already knows
that it's me in control?
This is just the
first step in creating
seamless, magical,
secure authentication
for your mobile device.
With time, we will
extend the means
to establish the
phone is with you.
And with multiple
devices around you,
we're working on many
more exciting ways
to interact between devices
while not just maintaining,
but even increasing
your security.
I hope you are as excited by the
possibilities of authentication
as I am.
Thank you for watching.